make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back once again with another
installment of our beyond omega-level
series where we focus on the most
powerful characters in all of comics and
today we're focusing on none other than
the all-father of all the Asgardians
Odin
now the Marvel Comics version of Odin
was adapted from the Odin of Norse
mythology by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
really more Jack urban Stan Lee and
first appeared in journey into mystery
number 86 and 1962
now Odin is the son of the Asgardian
ruler boar and Bela a frost giant from
the realm of Jotunheim
although Bor had two older sons it was
Odin that he singled out and groomed to
be a successor as ruler of Asgard and so
Odie gains a reputation as a mighty
warrior alongside his brothers V Lee and
V now when the three brothers battled
the demon Surtur Odin is able to defeat
him but his brothers are slain in the
process the result is that Odin absorbs
her life energy and thus the odinforce
is born now shortly after his victory
over Serdar Odin claims the role of all
father when his father abdicates the
throne of Asgard and of course we owe
Odin would go on to become the father of
Thor and Loki we've also recently
learned that Odin was one of the members
of the first Avengers team on earth
found in 1 million BC
to defend the Earth from an impending
celestial invasion and so Odin is widely
considered to be the most powerful of
all the Asgardians that has a variety of
powers
first of all Odin is thousands of years
old and like all ass Guardians his
lifespan is significantly lengthened by
the consumption of the golden apples of
at noon Odin also possesses
super-strength and has proven himself to
be comparable to Thor in terms of
strength and has also split a mountain
with one swing of his sword
Odin also has superhuman durability and
speed now much of Odin's power comes
from the odinforce and this is a vast
source of mystical energy that manifests
itself in a variety of ways all of them
extremely potent using the odinforce
Odin is capable of energy projection
matter manipulation interdimensional
travel creating illusions and time
manipulation among others the energy
blasts of Odin are powerful enough to
kill hella in one blast he's also able
to fire these blasts with such precision
that he hit a single human on earth
whilst aiming an Asgard Odin is also
able to grant or reduce the power of
others he's done so on multiple
occasions with Thor and has on occasion
done this his other sons Loki and Balder
in addition to stripping the powers of
gods Odin is also able to strip their
memories as he did when he sent for
to earth in an effort to humble him
erasing his memories to the point that
he did not even remember who he was but
believed himself to be a human named
Donald Lake Odin can also transfer a bit
of the odinforce to others as he saw
when he did so to save his wife Frigg
his life after she was stabbed by Loki's
poisonous dagger now Odin is powerful
enough to control time itself having
stopped time from passing on earth on
more than one occasion and has also
demonstrated a degree of clairvoyance as
he was able to predict the impending
invasion by the Celestials on one
occasion when the earth was about to be
invaded by Surtur and the storm Giants
CAG Odin stop time and transported all
of humanity to another dimension to
spare them from witnessing the ensuing
carnage that would come with Surtur and
Scaggs invasion but all those things
while impressive are really just the tip
of the iceberg that is Odin's vast power
when Odin battled for son a member of a
group of powerful magicians known as the
enchanters the energy produced by the
two of them was enough to shatter
planets with ease and even able to
create new suns in the wake of their
battle that waged across the galaxy
likewise when Odin fought infinity one
of the Marvel Universe's cosmic
abstracts the struggle between them
destroy not only planets but entire
galaxies granted both of these feats
occurred when Odin was fighting another
extremely powerful being but the fact
that Odin would be able to produce even
half this much energy is exceedingly
impressive and it's worth pointing out
that Odin defeats for song in their
altercation so we can assume that he's
more powerful than the two whose power
combined destroyed planets and created
new suns furthermore Odin is able to
defeat infinity by absorbing the cosmic
entity into himself which would
obviously require a ridiculous amount of
power and so following this battle Odin
was able to repair all the damage that
he and infinity had caused and erase it
from the minds of the entire planet
demonstrating that he's able to
manipulate the power of those he absorbs
as well now one of the more notable
examples of Odin's ability to manipulate
matter comes when he summons a mass of
electromagnetic particles from space and
concentrates them above the earth to
make a beginner's rotation which traps
serda within the earth through
centrifugal force he also commands the
entire floor to soften causing scag the
storm giant to sink into it and on
another occasion he alters the force of
gravity by making Loki and the absorbing
man become weightless before hurling
them into space now because the
odinforce
is a mystical form of energy Odin is
able to perform a variety of magical
feats for instance he creates the
Bifrost
the Rainbow Bridge that allows rapid
travel between asgard and midgard he's
also able to create a spell so strong
that a more of the Enchantress is unable
to negate its effects
Odin is also aided in battle by gun gear
a sphere made of goo the same material
that makes up Thor's hammer mjolnir gun
gear is an exceedingly durable weapon in
his own right but is made even more
formidable in that it's mystical
properties allow Odin to use it to
channel the odinforce one notable
drawback of the odinforce though is that
it is not inexhaustible every year Odin
is forced to enter a 24-hour Odin's
sleep in order to replenish his energy
stores and while he is in the Odin sleep
he is 100% and completely vulnerable to
attacks and so Asgard devotes all of its
security to watch over him and make sure
that no harm befalls him during this
state of vulnerability
now Odin's also proven himself against
several other heavy hitters in the
Marvel Universe ranging from traditional
threats like the frost giants Serdar and
Magog to cosmic threats such as Thanos
Galactus and a Celestials as well as
infinity although he is Rayleigh in the
spotlight due to the fact that most of
the tales regarding Marvel Comics focus
on for Odin has been able to amass quite
a list of feats that definitely merit
him as a classification of being beyond
omega-level but having said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end let me
know what you think down in the comments
section let me know who you think we
should do a video on next I don't recall
if we did a video on man GOG if we
didn't we definitely should we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]